good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast it is Friday it looks
like the world is ending outside it
feels like the world is ending inside
but the morning toast is here because we
are the thing you can rely on yeah we
will be here and tell us until they tell
us that we cannot be here we will keep
you here until 4:00 we can't keep them
past 4:00 we will keep you here until
4:00 yeah no I mean there's like so much
going on in the world and I actually
went shopping this morning because I'm
so paranoid about food I'm not even
paranoid about the corona virus I am
paranoid that people are gonna be
paranoid and shut down their restaurants
and I can't get food right and that'll
keep food in my house I don't have a
working stove or an oven so I'm just
concerned about my food and I've gone
grocery shopping a few times and I ran
into my friends in the grocery store and
they were like panicking buying tampons
Oh was I because there's a rumor now
going around like tampons are out of
shortage but I can't hopefully like the
coronavirus doesn't last more than one
cycle right also if I'm home all the
time and I'm on my period I'll just like
sit on the toilet the whole time you
know they're like at the beverlyks on a
bale of hay like they used to yes bleed
out but they were my leaving my house
who cares what's happening to me they
were like why you wearing makeup
and I'm like I gotta work yeah no but
and I had my friends over for a game
night last night which was such a smash
success and they were like here late you
know I'm like they're like we're working
from home I'm like I'm not no but like I
feel as though there's no place I'd
rather be than here in the morning toast
talking to all of you same and it's
interesting how Coronas really affecting
the market we spoke about this yesterday
but it's like certain industries are at
an all-time low like the SP is dropped
at that point Wall Street had their
worst day since 1987 but certain
industries are prospering Lysol is like
the best it's ever been P&G I think is
just thriving grocery stores around the
world are at the I literally went to
Duane Reade yesterday to get toilet
paper and the owner of the store he was
so cute he was literally taking pictures
of all of his shelves he's like I've
never seen this before and I'm like it's
amazing he's like yeah he was really
excited oh that's cute you know like
some businesses are really thriving and
the toast is one of them my friend
Jordan last night was like are you like
doing your podcast I'm like literally
we've never been bigger yeah it's it's
crazy times we're here for you the
stores people are sort of panic
which I wouldn't recommend but I do
think it's important to think about if
you had to spend two weeks at home do
you have food right and so to me I'm not
really panicked about the virus I think
like America's doing a great job like
we're containing it I'm just nervous
about the precautions people are gonna
take that will allow me not to eat and
that's what I'm nervous yeah I feel that
I do feel as though we are doing a good
job of flattening this curve and taking
the necessary precautions early on
because eventually we'd have to cancel
these all these events anyway might as
well do it before more people die and
you know I'm really thankful for a lot
of things I'm thankful that I found out
that Tom and Rita Hanks are they're
still not tripping so that's good like
that is pretty much all we needed to
know and secondly I hate to rub it in
people's faces like I'm so glad my tour
is over I just would not want to deal
with canceling shows disappointing
people like having to return their
tickets all that stuff I'm really
grateful that I'm not in that position
and I'm like seeing like other artists
who are and it just sucks it sucks
pretty much every show or large
gathering has been cancelled or
postponed Broadway has been shut down
for a month Broadway has been shut down
that's crazy Erika James she never got
to like wrap up her role as Roxy I think
in Chicago she just had to like stop
doing it one day now she's back in LA
which is like not how you want to go out
no it's not but like I would be glad to
like quit while I'm ahead
yeah yeah of course no and then I'm sure
by the way doing Broadway is exhausting
I'm sure she's like low-key happy like
all that hard work is over yeah but she
probably like not everyone that she
wanted to see her probably was able to
see her yeah etc so it's just crazy tie
it's crazy times Liam's put a cancel
production on her show I think she's not
she's going off the air Joy Behar is not
attending the view she doesn't feel safe
Wow yeah I get because you have to buy
they people were like we talked about it
very casually but it is really like a
risky thing like if we caught
coronavirus like hopefully God like we
would be in a lot of pain but we would
be fine but for some people it's much
more risky and I totally respect
people's decisions to like not go to
work joy behar is a woman of a certain
age I completely agree if you are over
60 you are more at risk but that is why
us young people need to be aware as well
because we can become human vectors for
the disease and spread it to more people
at risk yeah it's like the Millennial
entitlement just like walking around
thinking that it doesn't apply to us but
like you could be carrying it over to
Grandma's house that's where we need to
it just like evaluate
yeah just be cautious you know and just
be thoughtful and mindful and just keep
watching them hand so the morning shows
is obviously here to keep you updated on
all things coronavirus but we're also
here to uplift spirits I think there's a
lot of anxiety a lot of panic and some
people just want to like enjoy and like
go back to the simpler time so we were
talking about Ben Affleck and Anna Dorma
so we're gonna do that too
we're gonna do all of it you know
coronavirus obviously top of mind but so
is the bachelor yeah and there's just so
much still crazy stuff going on and the
world does feel like it's ending and you
know I'm gonna go soda at 10:00 in the
morning on the morning to us it's a dr.
pepper and yeah I'm drinking it out of a
blessing straw because you know what the
oceans are gonna be fine because we're
all gonna be dead yeah do your thing sis
do your thing
love to see it okay well I think it's
time to just jump right in headfirst
into exactly should dive off the deep
end
ooh that seems crazy it does I think we
should just start by jumping in okay now
that I got money coming right into the
fast high stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast yep that's true
Jackie it's very true and as always do
regular scheduled programming today's
episode is brought to you by zip
recruiter they send your job application
to over a hundred top job sites and they
don't stop there they have a powerful
matching technology zip recruiter can
scan thousands of resumes to find people
with the right skills and experience at
free our job listing and it actively
invites them to apply you can even add
screening questions to your job listing
so you can filter candidates and focus
on the best one zip recruiters so
effective that four out of five
employers who post on zip recruiter get
a quality candidate within the first day
68% of employers have raised their wages
according to zip recruiter research and
nearly three-fourths of their employers
say they're finding it difficult to find
open positions so now's the time you
guys you could try zip recruiter for
free our listeners can go to zip
recruiter dot-com slash toast
that's a zip recruiter comm slash tio
ast if you're looking for you know a
graphic designer
whatever it is you need someone zip
recruiters got you they'll send your job
application to hundreds of candidates
invite them to apply and you can find
the Claudia do your Jackie the Jackie
dear Claudio you looking for a co-host
you never know super cooter comm slash
toast it's the smartest way to hire and
if you want to try it for free you got
to go to zip recruiter dot-com slash
zip recruiter the smartest way to hire
thank you for sponsoring today's episode
zipper Kurt art we see you and
appreciate you sign on hire smartly okay
first episode story excuse me excuse me
I'm sure you do you feel okay I feel
okay I'm sorry first story the bachelors
Peter Webber and Madison Pruitt have
ended their relationship two days after
the dramatic finale we've been waiting
for them to post something on Instagram
follow each other something something
instead they've both posted like PR
person approved statements Peter saying
Maddie and I have mutually decided to
not pursue our relationship any further
they both think ABC and the women and
the men and the journey and they are
going their separate ways
makes me think were they even together
and after the final room yeah no it was
all very boring like I didn't even get
excited about this because I should have
been it was an update about like things
something I'm interested in but it was
all very calculated and I I had thoughts
on The Bachelor and let's let's let's
roleplay for a minute like we believe
everything that happened on after the
final rose of course Maddie and Peter
we're never gonna work out and honestly
I commend them for not even giving it a
chance because when the the relationship
with your in-laws is so toxic like it's
never gonna work yes of course they were
never gonna work out but the way they
were talking on the show like love
conquers all like we will get past this
you tried two days of dating if we're
really believing everything that we saw
on the show this makes no [ __ ] sense
you try it today for two days and you
couldn't even [ __ ] hack it love
conquers nothing right so I'm just now
more confused than ever
about what actually went down and I feel
as though we're never gonna find out and
I don't know I feel like the way I felt
about Maddie is maybe not what I should
be feeling think so obviously everyone's
talking about how she was hanging out
with Selena Gomez last night like
everyone's quarantined and then like she
went to Walmart with Selena Gomez picked
up a couple board games and then played
them in her living room now
I would like to assess how we think this
came to be because I see it as this I
see this as all these celebrities are
now watching a batch or the Kardashians
whatever Selena Gomez similar to how
Gigi Hadid just like saw Tyler si and
was like you know I could have any one I
want like I choose him he's handsome
whatever I want a nice guy right I want
like a handsome you know tall regular
American dude I totally see how that
could have come to fruition
I think similarly Selena Gomez saw
Maddie on The Bachelor and was like you
know what I am like in this new place in
my life member she took that long break
no one really knows what she did but I'm
pretty sure she got sober Maddie is like
this really faith-based person who
doesn't drink like she could be a really
good influence in Selenas life and I
feel like Selena just saw it was like oh
I want that friend ya know where I think
Selena saw her on TV and was like just
felt a kinship towards her probably
reached out and was like you go girl
like I'm rooting for you bah bah bah and
they had some like DM exchanges and then
like realized they were in the same city
and been like let's play some more games
yeah I think that it's obviously very
genuine how the friendship came to be I
think they have a lot in common but it
does make me like just think differently
about Maddie you know yeah because there
have been two storylines here selena
gomez cars you answered the call so
people are like she was always thirsty
and we knew it on the show and now we're
confirmed but what she's not gonna sing
I was like just make you happy she was
thirsty if she was thirsty she would
have been thirsty for the Instagram
followers the ads I follow suit never
having to get a nine-to-five job for the
rest of her life
I think the Selena Gomez loved it all
level of it all is not anything that she
expected like I don't think Tyler's he
ever went on The Bachelor expecting to
come out dating Gigi Hadid no and now
things like this things like Kim
Kardashian posting that she loves Hannah
and Selena Gomez hanging out with her
with um Maddie and Gigi didn't Tyler see
like it is going to create a new breed
of thirst monsters to come on the show
and I think that the Claire Crawley of
it all might put a brief pause to that
which I'm excited about
I don't know her guys seem like the same
old batch of guys even if it had been
Hannah Ann as the Bachelorette yeah it
doesn't seem like anything was really
changed it's just I can't believe we're
not three seasons in three seasons in a
row with no real ending and no couple
know we have Colton and Cassie still oh
right right but no engagement knowing
gage and now we're two seasons in a row
of no relationship at all which is so
crazy so crazy and so weird and I feel
like back in the day they used to fake
it like I always think of crystals and
Whitney who were like literally the
least compatible people in the world and
they broke up fairly shortly after but
still them six months like yeah now
we're were two months no we can't even
do two days yeah we can't even do two
days so I'm just confused like what's
what's going on yeah I think it also has
to do with like the rise of social media
like crystals in Whitney like they
probably there was Instagram
probably posted once in a while but now
it's like we follow everyone's lie life
24 hours of the day and like if Maddie
wants to hang out with Selena Gomez but
she's still supposed to be dating Peter
like why isn't Peter there well we start
to ask these questions they want to move
on with their lives yes they just have
to be more transparent if they want to
be able to move on and not have to like
be seen with each other yeah it's just
all so strange to me and to me like
Peter was top two of the worst bachelors
I've ever watched yeah do you think we
will continue to feel that way or when
you're watching it you're always like
he's the worst you know I think when
you're watching it you're always hard on
that about Ari
yeah you're always hard on them even
Colton who I used to love him on Beca
C's and remember Monica said snitch I'm
his season and then on his season I like
I still kind of liked him but I liked
him much much less the same goes for
Jojo whenever someone is the lead like
they just you start to disagree because
you got agree with everything that they
do
sometimes you really like I fell in love
with Kaitlyn Bristowe I thought she was
the best Bachelorette like she was
[ __ ] cutthroat she had no time for
anyone's [ __ ] she would literally in
the middle of the day be like you know
what I'm not feeling this you should go
home yeah I love that I feel the same
about Rachel Lindsay same but yeah I do
think it's it's almost impossible to
just be what everyone wants you to be
especially when the edits come in
because then they might edit someone for
a bachelorette edit and you're like why
aren't they why isn't the lead picking
this personally towards the end it
starts to be it's not about Peter
anymore it's about who they're editing
charming for the nation for the nation
for bachelor in paradise so then you
don't understand why he's picking
certain people when it's not even when
what you're seeing isn't what he's
seeing totally so it just becomes but
then when you get like if he makes his
choice in six with it and this a year
later and they're married and they have
a baby we have absolutely no choice but
to stand and that's what happens I think
people worse I think nobody got more
negative comments just had such people
[ __ ] hated ari and Lauren because
they felt like they were the villains
and Becca was the victim even though
like Ari did everything right and gave
back of that Bachelorette ship on a
silver platter and she ended up meeting
the love of her life so like everyone
should be happy there but people were so
mean to R and Lauren and took a really
really long time they literally it's
like get married have a kid and like
become grandparents in order for people
to think that they were male and I think
people are still really hard on them but
they they eventually came like now
they're well loved by everyone but
they were they got so much [ __ ] yeah
they did but you know he made a big a
really big [ __ ] mistake yeah for sure
but people make mistakes and it's always
how you handle it that says more about
you and I thought he handled it very
gracefully but that's a really big
mistakes making proposing to the wrong
girl when the right one was just
standing in front of you waiting to be
proposed of course there was it wasn't
even like a Peter situated so obvious
that she was the winner yeah and also I
think Ari had two girls in front of him
who like loved him and wanted to marry
him whereas I think Peter had Hannah
Hannah and Mady neither of whom wanted
to be engaged right so at the end of the
day I fault Peter because to me he makes
the wrong decisions in the sense that
not there's anything wrong with him but
the two girls he ended up with at the
end were not the girls for him for a
million different reasons like the fact
that he had all these girls he had
Kelsey had Kelly and he still ended up
with Hannah and Mady nothing wrong with
them just they're not for him so to me
that's why he's not because he made the
wrong choice because as whittled down
Victoria F was there for him if he's a
man that he's saying he is which is
someone who wants to get married yeah
but if he's someone who just like wants
to be a plus-one at revolve festival and
they are certainly which I dragged that
vibe from him no but me I'm getting that
vibe everyone's like saying crazy [ __ ]
about him and like I don't believe some
of the wilder things that I've heard but
that I got Kelly pregnant I heard that
like I don't even want to say it because
it's an early slam there is oh it's like
people are just saying and I don't
believe this for one second that he was
coked out all season
oh my god by the way I saw someone
saying that too which is 100% not true
like first of all in order to be on The
Bachelor like you're filming living from
the second you make up to the second go
to bed like you cannot be on drugs okay
that is 100% not true we are like not
spreading that out but yeah I'm coming
for him now I crazy it's good it's
actually sad it's really sad so now
you're like fandom you know I watched
david dobrik um on hot ones and he said
the most genius saying I don't even
think he was like trying to be um a
genius but he ended up being one cuz he
was talking about how like he's so much
of his life is online and the guy was
like when does it go too far he's like
well people like come over to my house
at 11:00 at night and like want to hang
out they think they're my friend and he
was like what do you mean like fans he's
like no that those are not fans like
fans respect your boundaries which is
like such a well said thing because
sometimes people take things too far and
like this is where bachelor nation gets
crazy like they're fans of the show but
then they're literally like they ruined
people's lives - yeah and they think
that they're just doing it as a fan I'm
obsessed with the show Peter was on coke
you know yeah no you're ruining his life
yeah you're not a fan no I don't think
there's any truth to that rumor and it
takes away from any of the other
conspiracies that might be true which is
that like Kelly might be pregnant
know which is that like Peter and Kelly
are in a relationship but then Nick
Viall posted yesterday that Kelly is not
with Peter and like it was giving me the
vibe that maybe she's with no of course
and Kelly was in a picture with Nick and
Chris Harrison was over there commenting
love seeing you two get so cozy last
night oh my god she's anywhere here for
it oh my god what is he and then I saw
an interim he was like Chris Harrison is
finally clearing up those producer
conspiracy theory rumors I'm like he was
the one perpetuating the rumors like
it's just I can't oh my god I actually
can't I ship Nick vile and Kelly so hard
but now that Chris two entire sin is
commenting like his we never see a [ __ ]
on it I'm out I'm out but I could just
like can you think of the stimulating
conversations going on between Kelly and
Peter I mean sorry Nick so stimulating
so he's so welcome she's in a lawyer
like I could just see it I know but now
I think there's no truth to it either
but I also think there's no truth to
Kelly and Peter either me neither I
think and to be honest I don't want
Kelly to end up with Peter like in the
second in the season I did because she
was the best given more weeks of her on
my TV yeah and like Peters only dude
with it miles Blake now that she has the
world is her oyster Peter is not the man
for her
okay next story Bachelorette star Tyler
Cameron returns to work after his
mother's death that's great yeah the
reality star returned to New York on
Thursday for modeling work and made it a
family affair by bringing along his
younger brother Ryan Cameron who also
took part in this shoot I was watching
his Instagram stories and he posted on
his feed and they just like seemed like
they're having a good time I mean
they're with their families yeah I
didn't expect him to come back to work
so quickly but I'm sure he has like so
much waiting for him because like the
busiest time in his life and it's truly
I think I don't know her but what his
mom would have wanted right so I'm happy
that they're spending time together and
that he's he's getting back to it he's
such a paid job like I really love him
and I just want him like to have all the
success money fame like I just want it
all for him me as well but you did see
that Hannah Brown was like spotted with
him at the mall in Florida yeah I don't
think they're dating but she's just
being a good friend
yeah I think that was also before she
got the news at him and Matty broke
so now she's in LA right I just
personally like I'm done with Hannah
brown like I I'm absolutely on with her
and the more that I think about it her
and Peter are genuinely perfect for one
another and I really do hope that and in
in some way or another you know in time
they find their way back to each other
because they're they are meant for each
other they're both like indecisive but
they're just perfect for each other and
I hope that they live happily ever after
but I'm officially done like giving it
my I just can't anymore I'm done with
her and I know Margo loves stands like
would die for her and I just don't even
see how anyone could like she's
infuriatingly like flakey yeah well she
also hasn't like done anything in the
last month like no you know she's just
but it's not her fault like every time
she farts like people talk about it but
as a consumer of pop culture like I'm
done yeah I hear you and that's my
official statement I hear you I hear you
I see you you you hear me yeah okay I'm
here for you as well thank you oh by the
way oh that's all that matters yeah okay
next up little coronavirus news Broadway
is shutting down all productions over
coronavirus pandemic music how the
charge will automatically refund
purchase tickets for person for
performances between March 12th and
April 12 when it comes to ticketed
events like a cancellation is the most
annoying thing you could do because okay
I would say maybe half the audience
actually about tickets to tell a charge
like you know they buy it on the street
they buy two tickets take a ticket so I
don't stub up like more like it's very
likely that most these people get their
money back
really yeah I didn't even think about
that like when it comes to tickets like
so many like scalpers like they buy mass
tickets and then resell them like when I
buy tickets to show unless I'm like the
first person online cuz I'm obsessed
with Kacey Musgraves and I'll get the
waiting list the password I'll just buy
on StubHub like yeah so I guess how does
he work on StubHub like Ticketmaster
might refund the seller but the seller
might not refund you I don't know how it
works
that is interesting I haven't thought of
it I I mean I didn't want to think about
it because it was just that's too sad I
just wanted to assume that it all works
itself out or like you literally buddy
see people selling tickets on like
Facebook marketplace or like Skylar's
it's just like these poor people who
want to just have a fabulous night in
New York you know I know taking a trip
leaving their farm and they don't get
their money back and it's just
depressing yeah well let's just hope
that like most of them thought them
through telecard you know right and
that's that would be a nice thing I mean
that would be ideal I mean this is like
a number
Siddhant didn't move I know same another
unprecedented with Disney is closing
their parks right which they haven't
done like they've only done four times
since they've been in business which is
crazy wow that is crazy so a few more
updates the NCAA has canceled this
year's March Madness tournament which is
crazy because yesterday we said they
were just gonna play with our fans the
MLB has AK Spring Training and delayed
the start of the regular season for at
least two weeks the NHL is suspending
the remainder of the season
Hollywood that's in Furious 9 and a
quiet place to and mulan are being
pushed back by the place - yeah well
that's crazy
yeah it was like just premiered so yeah
John Krasinski posted that they're gonna
wait and mulan which like I really am
excited to see that meet you and I just
saw the trailer know there was a big
premiere right right I follow Dorothy
wearing on Instagram she was there I
hope that um like some of these movies
should be on demand like remember with
the interview yeah but then it's like
you don't yeah but I can charge $25 for
the movie yeah I mean everyone's who's
home can watch it and they might not
because you have so many options like
and by the way like some of these movies
like will make in their first week like
100 million dollars like it's a major
loss it's a major if they were just to
release it on demand like waiting is the
fiscally responsible thing to do I think
yeah but analysts are estimating that
the outbreak could cost five billion
dollars in lost box office revenues this
year crazy crazy so those are the latest
stuff I just don't feel bad for like
Hollywood you know like they're them in
their five least say have 5 billion
dollars to lose you know like I think
the corona virus is gonna end up
affecting like small businesses more
than anything else yeah an hourly wage
workers who aren't being able to work so
I watched a press conference interview
where Mark Cuban was asked about what
he's gonna do and he said we were trying
to get he doesn't he said I don't it's
not too early to have any details but
we're trying to get a program in place
where people still get compensated for
those hours but instead of working maybe
they'll volunteer like something like
they're working on it which I thought
was great and Kevin Love decided to
generate a hundred thousand dollars to
the Cavaliers like arena staff which is
so cool I think more players should step
up and do that yeah today King Charles
Cavaliers yeah okay the best and most
important team next up a story in a bit
of podcasting and first-amendment news
this is so fabulous Heather McDonald
scores victory in Jim Bellino defamation
lawsuit Heather McDonald was granted her
request to have Jim Bellino's defamation
lawsuit against her dismissed / Orange
County Superior Court documents obtained
by Paige Thicke 6 on Thursday the
podcaster argued that she was was in her
First Amendment rights when she hosted
the live juicy scoop podcast taping with
Tamra and Shannon with her lawyer filing
an anti SLA PP motion to plead her case
the judge agreed with McDonald in a
preliminary ruling which was made
permanent earlier this week she said
she's really happy I feel in a much
better state now that we have an actual
ruling in our favor so we knew about
this lawsuit a bid for meal hours of
course Orange County and how it was
affecting Shannon and Tamara but we
didn't even stop to consider how Heather
McDonald might be involved and she did
like a short interview with the New York
with page 6 and I read it and it was
really really sad she was like you don't
know what it's like like I live in a
regular house like someone literally
just came up to my door and served me
and she said like she literally hasn't
slept since and she's been having panic
attacks like she's a mom like she's a
business to run and like kids to feed
and this lawsuit has been like running
her dry and it's so sad and you
obviously hear so much about like
Shannon and the bills but you know like
Shannon and Tamara are TV stars like
Heather is running a business and so why
this is a big deal is because like when
let's say like John Oliver or like James
Corden were to get sued they're
protected as like freedom of the press
but like a podcast is like this weird
new medium and so like this is the first
time whereas like if let's say we ever
were to get sued we could point to her
lawsuit as precedent and yeah they're
big on precedent here huge she's a
trailblazer she by the way she's a
trailblazer in podcasting and I've
always said that she was like the first
one to start podcasting about reality TV
and now she's like a legal present
predecessor yeah she's gonna be like in
the books like Jim Bellino is a little
[ __ ] I'm sorry I either sure like if
you're gonna go on reality TV and be an
[ __ ] like you have to accept the fact
that like people are gonna talk [ __ ]
about you right and so what he didn't
hansu everyone
and like you chose this public lighter
yourself he um he he lost his Shannon
and ended up having to pay her legal
bills of 140 thousand dollars so like
when you decide to take on a case your
lawyer advises you like what your odds
are like what does the law say like
things can go wrong but you're more than
likely so he must have known he wasn't
likely to win this Heather McDonald or
the Shannon beador case but he still did
it
because he had the money and means to
like basic basically like financially
bully these women and he's just like a
little [ __ ] yeah yeah we should be
careful what we say about him I
literally never want to speak about him
on the show like for a million reasons
yeah this is just another one in Andy's
book he talks a lot about I'm house
husbands who call him when their wives
get fired off the show saying that they
all like quit their jobs put all their
eggs in this basket and he never names
names but in the book I really got the
vibe that when he was talking about like
the house husband who literally called
him sobbing that it was Jim Bellino Oh
God but he didn't say who no wow it was
just my guess well I'm really happy for
her michio this is so fabulous like I'm
so glad that this is over for her
obviously Jim Bellino appealed but she
said she's not worried about it like
it's yeah it's an it's a nothing piece
out okay fifth and final story a little
sad is news sporting goods chain
Modell's is closing its remaining store
got it but I have heard this story like
he 500 times they have been for the last
10 years it's like a scheme going out of
business go shopping Motel South because
I I swear we've reported on this
multiple times and I'm a special place
in my heart for motels because of that
Undercover Boss episode where he went on
to be all of you not once but twice it
ended up giving someone a house so I
stand the motel I think they're our
family
yeah they are but oh you're saying that
this isn't I've just heard this like a
million times
okay well motels sporting goods for
people who are hearing it for the first
time motels the century owned
family-owned sporting goods chain has
filed for chapter 11 bankruptcy and will
be closing its remaining 100-plus stores
well there's a little hundred stores
mm-hmm it becomes the latest traditional
retailer to succumb to a fast changing
environment in recent years Payless Shoe
Source Corp Toys R Us in children's
chain Gymboree have filed for chapter 11
reorganization or liquidated their
operations so when you file for chapter
11 it doesn't mean that your business is
done it means you're like restructuring
yes but they are closing the stores
these will be our online support a I
mean no I don't I think at this point
they missed the boat on us yeah because
um you know Amazon like they who would
go shop at motels online to be honest it
is so difficult to be like a retail
chain in this current environment but
like also for something so specific like
how many [ __ ] you know soccer socks
do you need you know it's just it's
honestly too
Anish I don't know sporting-goods it's a
big category I know but it's like if you
ain't dicks you ain't it yeah cuz man
it's it you know what it's like but like
motels is everything I mean I feel like
some people don't know what mode else is
but it's like you're from New York you
do yeah and it was [ __ ] even when I the
first time we had camp dos and I was
like oh I need to get camp clothes I'm
going to move down no of course because
we have it's like we grew up and needed
our Sophie shorts me always got them
from Odell's and that was a special time
for us and I totally understand the
connection I don't think other people
might relate to it though and a lot of
people do some people don't obviously
but it is the go-to I don't think I've
ever been to Dix it might be the bigger
sporting goods chain but well it's also
the controversial
I'm Modell's loyal and I don't know
where I'm gonna take all my loyalty it's
just it's weird to think that like of
the two you know sporting good chains
the one named dicks survived yeah and
they're very controversial because they
sell guns you know yeah maybe that's why
they're saying business cuz you know
people love guns
customers will be able to participate in
a liquidation sale beginning today
oh how excited are you is online um well
you know what I'm not gonna lie the last
time I went to Modell's
I didn't really get a lot of help and I
wound up buying some stuff that I never
wore and things that I did were where
which was a pair of socks and I couldn't
find my size so I wound up wearing socks
that were too small for a few months and
they really hurt my toes so I can see
what how this happened
when I said I was wearing the wrong size
socks and my toes were starting to be
like ingrown yes oh yes because no one
would [ __ ] help me find my size I get
my socks exclusively via my
mother-in-law who gets them from Costco
and like every like month or so I get
like a present left in my doorman and
it's kb socks from Costco and I think
saver you're a real one and KB socks
like that used to where I'm in so it's
like they also bomb the socks are great
oh my god am i game night I made
everyone take off their shoes and wash
their hands and leave their jackets and
like backpacks and shoes outside my
house um someone was running bomba socks
and I was like did use Koto's and he
said no I guess I got to hear it but
even though his mom's a big toaster like
she should have told him okay fine I'll
allow it then anyways if you've got to
go to Moe's you should do it soon if you
got a good pose you can't because soon
you won't be able to get ill-fitted
socks it's weird though that like the
like we still have stuff to report on
like that the world is still turning
even though it's mostly the weather but
it really feels like the world is ending
I know but even though everyone is like
saying
home and not going to work like there
were so much traffic this morning did
you know we were talking about how there
was literally no traffic oh no I was
just like sitting in it no I was not
maybe yeah it was behind a garbage truck
no oh mom said he drove into city and
there was like literally not a soul oh
wow okay and it's also the weekend I
think part of the the the pandemonium is
like the weekend is kind of scary
because like nothing goes on normally on
the weekend so you're like what's really
gonna happen when the world is anything
on the weekend but I think also on the
weekend like if you're not working
there's no reason to leave your house
this weekend so you do need to have like
enough food for you and your family for
to get you until Monday and who knows
where we'll be on Monday I have a
feeling like to me like the scary part
and like the uneasiness I'm feeling is
really mostly due to the weekend I think
on Monday like things will like be back
to normal we're on Monday we'll have a
better sense of what's gonna happen
there were major I think part of what we
can all do to help like is to stop
spreading false information and I
honestly meant to call on my sister
Margot for like literally gas lighting
our whole group chat yesterday with like
these screenshots like my friend's
brother sister-in-laws mother works for
the NYPD and he said they're shutting
down the entire city and like I just
can't with all the misinformation and
literally the NYPD tweeted like all caps
we are not closing down mass transit
stop spreading this information I like
that's the most dangerous thing you
could do right not only sheis gas
lighting and spreading false information
but she's also refusing to take it
seriously he was like I got a fabulous
reservation this weekend I'm like I'm
sure you know she's canceling oh yeah
I'm sure you can get a reservation
anywhere right now so what are we gonna
do we're just gonna sit in our houses
all weekend yeah which is what we do
every weekend let's not pretend like
this is something that it is in yeah but
now that they're telling me that I have
to like I kind of want to go out you
know I know
but we'll find like some good stuff to
watch I finished watching myth millions
last night oh well you know what I'm
gonna take that on I really want to
watch up um and it was annoying because
I watched the first three parts like
week to week and then I just can't watch
a documentary like that so I watched the
last three parts last night and I think
it was dragged out too much having a
week two weeks documentary it's just
nothing of the sort and the end was so
not it not fabulous it was not fabulous
it was so depressing justice I do not
feel like was served and it just like
left a bad taste in my mouth I was just
like not I wasn't happy with it it made
me really [ __ ] sad sorry
people got likes women will be swindled
bamboozled and with my and hoodwinked as
well and then like the person who was
doing all of that like no justice the
person was doing the hoodwinking no no
justice okay well there's a siren coming
so I think we should wrap up that's the
show thank you guys so much flows into
the morning to us a Millenial morning
show where we go live Monday through
Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern Time on
YouTube so if you're watching us on
YouTube please feel free to subscribe
give this video a thumbs up leave a
comment were also available as a podcast
anywhere podcasts can be found set
Spotify iTunes stitcher Public Radio I
her videocast box all the places whoever
you listen to podcasts find out some
morning toast leave a five star review
maybe a comment about how beautiful
stunning and smart we are I don't know
there's tons of content if you're
looking for it this weekend new TNN
shows the first episode of maternity Lib
just dropped there's a new episode of
the redheads caviar dreams tunafish
budget mood with lauren elizabeth if you
head over to itunes chose news network
it has everything that you need so tons
of episodes to keep you busy while
you're quarantined and there's a new
episode coming of our patreon we did a
general Q&A the morning toast patron is
patreon.com slash the morning toast if
you're looking for like some real things
to do this weekend I would recommend
starting the redheads book club book
which is nothing to see here by Kevin
Wilson I've heard that it's really good
I haven't read it yet and then you can
also read last month's book red white
and royal blue and then listen to the
episode or you can even read the first
month's book the husband's secret and
listen to the episode there's so much
content so much time we love you guys so
much have a great weekend stay safe and
in your houses and stop spreading
misinformation bye